[Music]
my name is dancer Uli and I'm a product
manager here at Google and you I hope
are here to learn about SL OS and error
budgets this is the most awkward stage
I've ever been on
conveniently none of you are gonna look
at me the whole time so I guess it
doesn't matter
my name is dancer Uli I'm a product
manager at Google I've been here for
about six years working all on services
and API infrastructure and products I
now focus on sto and our service mesh
efforts both open source and in our
commercial products you will hear some
other voices today we will bring up
another very skilled product manager
from Google
Ruksana Dannette you and she will
she works exclusively really on on
service and SLO monitoring she thinks a
lot about the the role of the operator
the service operator and we're gonna
bring up one of our customers pod Sandhu
comes to us from Schlumberger very
experienced sre there where he not only
does spends his time kind of as an SRE
but also evangelizing best practices and
a couple of us are on twitter and one of
us i guess is refusing to join so i'm
gonna spend some time today talking to
you about SLO and error budgets rooks
andhe is then going to demonstrate some
of the software that we've been working
on and which is available in alpha today
and then pod and rooks and I are gonna
have a discussion about how they are
using the the Alpha software today and
how they think about SL OS and error
budgets and a fairly sophisticated
organization so we'll start by talking
about SL OS and error budgets and if
you've seen me talk about this before if
you've seen any of our SR ease you know
anytime we give a talk like this we
always start by talking about SL is SL
O's n SL A's and it may be review for
some people but for some people that get
confusing and it's under it's important
to understand what we mean is we refer
to each of them so we'll spend just a
slide talking about what each of them
are but SL eyes are metrics SL O's or
targets and SLA s are the prom
as you make about those so we start with
SL is the important thing to know is
that this is a a quantitative measure
you know there was a time when there was
up and there was down right there was a
time when is the site up is it down
dot-com was a thing we used and really
that's how we measured whether something
was working was was it up or was it down
but we've we've gotten past that and and
now we think about defined quantities
that we can measure so that we can all
in an organization from the people who
wrote the service to the people who are
running it agree on on what the targets
how we're going to set so it's it's an
aspect of the service the ones we
generally think of are what we at Google
call the golden signals for anyone who
has read the sre handbook you'll know
that the golden signals there's four
golden signals for a service there is
traffic helmet how much traffic is
hitting that service there is error rate
what percentage of those requests that
come in are not resulting in errors
there's latency and latency is not just
a single number but rather it's a bunch
of numbers we measure it's how long to
take a request we measure their the
volume of the time it takes to serve
requests but we do that at different
percentiles and the reason is that the
50th percentile your average request
length isn't always indicative of of
what's happening and what we tend to see
is that at the at the tale at the 90th
percentile the 95th depending on your
traffic levels 99th percentile you will
often see unacceptable results and so we
measured out there too and we often
devant use as SL eyes both the 50th
percentile and the 99th because it's not
you know you might say hey we want you
know under 200 milliseconds for for the
average user and that might be okay but
it might not be okay for the 99th to be
at 20 milliseconds and so it's important
to monitor those and agree that these
are things we're going to care about
there's a fourth golden signal that our
sres refer to as saturation and
saturation is different for different
services sometimes it might be hardware
related like it might be how much RAM is
being consumed or what CPU percentage
you're using but it can be different it
might be a number of current active
users yeah user sessions it can be
different for different
services and sometimes people define
custom metrics and they have their app
actually writing metrics out the
important part is that you agree in your
team's what you are going to measure now
sto for its part gathers most of these
it gathers traffic it gathers error
rates it gathers Layton sees so that you
can then have discussions about where
you want these metrics to be and that's
where we get into service level
objectives s ellos a service level level
objective is basically it's it's a
target it's what you consider to be
acceptable it's sometimes a a range
above you want to stay above like you
want your error your successful rate to
be above you say ninety-nine point nine
five percent of your of your of your
requests it might be a value you stay
below like you want 50 percent of your
of your requests returned in a hundred
milliseconds or less
I mean sometimes itting ends up being a
range as well these things can be
defined very very granular ly on on each
micro service in your application and
it's it's a good idea to do that we
believe strongly in measuring these
things for every single service that we
deploy and we do monitor every service
no matter how small we monitor these
metrics we are also moving to something
we call user centric s ellos and user
centric SLO s aren't defined in terms of
how long does it take this particular
service to return a request but rather
how long does it take from when a user
clicks say a Save button to when it
returns and that might involve lots and
lots of requests on the backend it might
involve a chain of requests from the
client and it almost certainly involves
measuring it from the client we're not
going to get too much into user centric
SLO s today they're they're actually a
fairly new thing that we're evolving on
in Google it's it's difficult to
instrument you know you might actually
have to start measuring in the in the
client app itself but it is an important
important concept to know about and and
one thing about an SLO is you may alert
somebody when you go out of compliance
with them you won't necessarily an
important concept that RS Ari's talk
about is is alert fatigue
just because you've set a goal and
you're not
meaning it momentarily doesn't mean you
need to wake somebody up in the middle
of the night we'll talk a little bit
more about alerting later and then
finally there says SLA s SLA SR
agreements you make with somebody about
your SLO a when I say you I mean you're
you're the producer of its service
sometimes these are informal it might be
just an informal agreement you have in
your company about hey you know we we
need your service that were depending on
to to you know sixty 99.9 percent of the
time it might me that the worst thing
you get is the ire of that team if you
violate it however these are often legal
agreements and those of you who are
Google cloud customers have probably
seen or at least heard about you know we
have pages where we document exactly how
we will intend to run the service and
what we will do for you if we don't in
that case it means generally rebates and
money and these are generally set on of
course the SLO s so we start with the SL
is we set objectives and occasionally we
make agreements about those objectives
so I said before we used to talk about
uptime alot and uptime was basically
well how much time was there total and
how much that time was up and what's the
ratio between those two right and that
made sense when a website went you know
when we were talking about sites and we
were talking about you know something
you could either it was either gonna
return or not the things are more
complicated now that that we deal with
services both of these graphics by the
way are taken from the SRA handbook now
we think more really about aggregate
availability where this will fact take
into account the fact that a service is
global it's not a single thing it's
running across the world in different
data centers and if it's down in one and
up in another is that up or is that down
well aggregate availability takes that
into account it's the number of requests
that that were attempted on in the
denominator and the numerator is the
total number of requests now
interestingly we still define our SL A's
in uptime at Google for many of our
services and to do that we combine them
and we'll say things like downtime is
any five minute period where more than
10% of our requests are failing and then
we make a request about downtime and I
mean when we make a guarantee about
downtime and
and how little of it we expect there to
be so in reality we are measuring
aggregate availability but we look at
that in discrete chunks so that we can
define uptime and define downtime and
really give an SLA that that people can
understand and now I want to talk a
little bit about error budget so that's
SL is SL o is SL A's now let's get into
error budgets the point behind budgets
is that every time you push new software
you're taking a risk when your system is
up and it's running and you're in stasis
it's probably going to stay running
unless you write memory leaks which I
know you don't but if you don't then
you're probably ok that the risky times
for software is when you're doing a
deployment every push is risky error
budgets exist to help us manage that
risk and basically you can think of it
as SLO that you can spend time that
you're within your SLO does not count
against your budget and time that you're
not within your SLO counts against your
budget so you define an SLO or a long
period of time we typically do this or a
month or often over a quarter and we say
as long as you are within budget you can
continue to push software you can
continue to take risks however that
budget exists over that quarter to help
you manage that risk and to force you to
manage that risk if every moment you're
out of compliance and you're spending
your budget and if if you go out of
budget you can't push new features you
can still push but everything at that
point can only be pushed to help improve
your infrastructure to help address the
problems that is that is making you your
system go down so your quality pushes
continue but your your feature pushes do
not continue if you have ever been
excited about a new feature you heard
about maybe at a conference like this
from Google and you were expecting it in
a certain quarter and it didn't ship
that quarter it may because engineering
is hard but it may be that they ran out
of budget and they literally weren't
allowed to push this is something that
we work very religiously that shouldn't
say religiously but we work very
diligently toward and this is something
that really aligns engineering teams and
operations teams the operations team is
really incented to to keep the system up
and running and and to build
infrastructure to
to system up and running that's what our
SRU do and if the and and they'll you
know push back on the dev team and if
the dev team won't do it well then
they're going to push something bad and
they're gonna run out of air budget and
so here you can see a chart where we've
got our SLO is a dotted line there it's
a red dotted line the time that we're
above we're not burning through our
budget and this is I chose one where
we're burning through a lot of budget
and if you look up top there I thought
we had one more build you can see we've
got 125 minutes remaining in our air
budget this is April there's two months
left the service is in dire trouble
right now because they've only got two
hours left they burned through 95% of
the budget so that's how you use a
budget it's to manage risk and and in
order to do it you really have to adopt
it for real and you really have to say
no one will push if we're out of budget
for the rest of the quarter when you
start looking at it that way it really
lets you let lets you let you manage
your risk on the other hand if it's
towards the end of the quarter and you
had a great quarter you could afford to
push more frequently there's a one of
the one in the original sre is a Google
used to say what's he used to having all
these nines if we don't take them out
for a spin once in a while when you got
lots of budget push it push it push
those features but it lets you manage
the risk it lets you reason together as
a development name as an Operations team
I talked a little bit about alerting
alerts are not necessarily for when you
are out of budget alert for when
something's on fire when something is
down when your error rate is over 10%
and you're on the Savannah the spanner
team you're you're getting woken up
that's what alerts are for budgets are
more like when your infrastructure needs
repair though if you're running out of
budget for a quarter it tells you you
need to spend some of your cycles right
now in improving your infrastructure and
include improving your test processes
improving your your release processes
that's where you should be spending your
time and a final note about Canaries one
of the reasons we do Canaries of course
is so that if there's a problem in a
service as we release it we don't affect
all of our users at once right of course
but these play into budgets as well
because when I canary my release and
expose it only to a small number of
users yes I am
I am you know guaranteeing that if
there's a problem it's only gonna affect
a small number of users but I'm also not
blowing my budget if there's a problem
and it affects a hundred percent of my
users for you know ten minutes that
might be my budget for the quarter if it
affects one percent of my customers for
ten minutes I might still have a budget
so one of the things we use Canaries for
is to help manage your budget and to
help make sure that you are again it's
it's really about risk management it's
about as making sure that you catch
these problems before they they affect
you overall so that's what I have about
SL OS and error budgets in theory now
rooks on des we'll talk a little bit
about what we've built in the software
and to allow you to do this stuff we
really appreciate it
understanding how these are silos work
and their budgets as well so at this
point we want to see how these actually
work in real life so what we are
actually trying to do here is that tank
driver has worked really closely with
these two your team and we wanted to
provide a solution a service management
solution that can empower users to get
out-of-the-box telemetry that requires
zero setup our main goal is to empower
all of our customers to have one single
dashboard for both management and
observability you have a single place
where you can go and look at all of your
metrics without having to worry about
agents without having to change context
without having to think about this too
long everything is out of the box for
you so I'm gonna welcome Patrick to the
stage Patrick is the lead engineer
working on service monitoring SLO
monitoring and topology graph and his
team has built a lot of the features
were going to demo today I had an
immense privilege of working with him on
the past couple of months of putting
this together so while Patrick sets this
up I want you really understandable
we're going to show right now it is the
Alpha product that we are launching at
next for service management so you're
coming here and you're gonna see a list
of all of your services your SEO
services that have deployed a steel mash
and really what we build embedded from
the beginning is SLO monitoring this is
one of the things that we cared about
deeply
so at the top you can easily see which
services have SLO based alerts firing or
not which of your services have a solos
out of the error budget and some
services exactly as Dan said some of
these services you're not going to set
up a salos for them you're not going to
end up alerting on them because not
everything is as important then we're
going to talk about how to prioritize
that in addition to this you can
actually review all of your services so
you get a list of all of your East your
services right here you can easily
filter based on the things you care
about and you get this out-of-the-box
telemetry what this view is missing is
that when you have imagine 300 500 of
these services it's really hard to
figure out what to prioritize what to
look for how to do root cause analysis
in this format so what Patrick's team
has built is a topology graph this is a
way for us to actually visualize all of
the relationships between these services
you can actually see at a glance how all
of this information gets transferred if
you hover on any of these services on
the left hand side you see the legend
that shows you which one our work loads
and which one our services so you can
difference between them and when you
hover on one of them you get actually
highlighted information of what are the
inbound and outbound services here you
can also see the QPS based on those
relationships as well so we I spend a
lot of time talking to customers when he
built this functionality and we really
wanted to get to the kind of the root
cause how do customers currently think
about their architecture and a lot of
the feedback that I received is that
there is a picture a really awesome
picture that's been sitting in a folder
for the past six months of a whiteboard
a PDF that hasn't been updated in two to
four years and every time they on board
somebody new to the team they have to
start taking a pen and paper and the
benefit of this if you look at the
bottom timeline it says 4:59 p.m. so
what happens here is that we are
extracting all of this information and
we give you a view of your architecture
right
now and this is key because you might
care about how your architecture is
today but let's say it's Monday morning
you come into the office you look at a
post mortem and you realize that you had
an incident on Friday at 4:00 p.m. and
you're reading the post mortem and you
have some questions you're trying to
evaluate what happened so we build this
feature we call it a time machine we
thought it was a cool name where you can
go back in time you can go and look at
your architecture at 4:00 p.m. on Friday
and you can see how all of your services
looked around that point and that is
great however that just gives you an
idea of how your world looked when the
incident happened
but what you care about is what has
changed so maybe you want to look at
your architecture an hour before and an
hour after and you can do that maybe
like switching really really really fast
and maybe you can get dizzy in the
process so what the team has built is
this notion of doing a time death
between these so you're looking at the
card service this is the service that
you see you have the alert and then you
notice that from the card service the
checkout service right there the
workload at the top is where the
information is coming through that's one
of the source so let's expand that for a
second and look at the car service you
look at the workload you see you have a
deployment and within that deployment
you notice that you have these parts so
ok this is good information you want to
see the world how it looked before and
after so let's turn the time default on
and be able to select two points in time
one hour before your alert and one hour
after so we can actually see the
differences between that workload and
see is there any change there can we
actually spot any difference between
those two so what were noticing here is
that are now before we had two pods and
an hour after the incidents we had five
this is helping you do route
cause analysis at a glance powerful
visual without having to go through a
bunch of logs without having to go
through a lot of metrics you can see
these differences right at the spot
right there and you can do this in
different modes this is kind of my
favorite one where you can actually
hover over and see us as these changes
are being made and the idea here is that
what we're trying to empower our users
is to be able to do your troubleshooting
as fast as possible and to do that in
the moment if it's a three o'clock in
the morning or to be able to put
yourself in the shoes of your developer
and operator to team even if it's days
or months afterwards so we've seen that
there is an issue there but we know that
your Lord happened on the cart service
so let's go back to the cart service
again let's see if we can get more
information about the cart service so as
we are exploring this we're noticing
that the cart service itself has an
alert around that time so when you click
on it we have the capability to get some
minimum information about it and we can
also have this link that says goes to
the service dashboard so let's explore
where that takes us
so what we build as long as you're using
the service mesh every single service
that you've deployed will have an
automatically generated out-of-the-box
dashboard for you everything that you
see right here requires zero setup the
only single thing that you will have to
do and that is your choice is to set up
an SLO for it so let's look at the top
we have an event timeline
this is scoped to one day in red we
actually see every single incident if
it's an oil that was caused by an SLO
based alert when you hover over it you
get information around the alert status
the time this alert was created and the
duration we have a deep integration with
iram the incidence response management
tool that will link you directly to that
alert for you to be able to do further
understanding of what happened there you
can go to your alert policy as well in
order to make changes to that alert
as we're looking at the table underneath
you see that we're on overview tab these
are the two key things that we
prioritize when you showed us we really
care about putting SLO health it's the
top one product another one priority for
you to monitor and then you also have at
a glance metrics and you have details
around your space let's go next to the
health tab this is where you're actually
going to spend a lot of your time
thinking about your SLO management so
we've created here 3's allows an
availability a latency and a second
latency one you can see that you get at
a glance overview of which ones are
healthy which ones having a lot firing
and which are out of SLO budget so let's
open one of them as an SLO gets created
you get an out-of-the-box mini dashboard
for that SLO that gets generated for you
you get a service level indicator an
error budget remaining and compliance
you get your allotted attach to it that
you can create based on every single SLO
so if you can collapse this for a second
what we can actually see is that our
first L SLO doesn't have policies
attached to it you can create us allows
that you monitor and you create a salons
that you alert on the entire creation
editing and deleting of an SLO our
target is that you need to accomplish
that under 30 seconds so let's try to
create an SLO right now there are three
main goal main features that you need to
add you decide you know SLO type and the
threshold for it you decide on your SLO
goal and then on the compliance period
as soon as you finish this you can click
Submit and we you can name it you get to
the full name but you can make this
personal and name than yourself once
this gets created what you can see is
that a solo has been generated
immediately but more importantly that
SLO has been evaluated so we because we
are able to get this information
directly from East year we can go and
look back
and pull this information in and do a
historical evaluation of your SLO and
give you a status within a couple of
seconds after this solo has been created
and we can delete it just as fast let's
look at the metrics tab next when we
think about metrics there's a lot of
when you think about monitoring there's
a lot of ancient deployment and there's
a lot of backend work everything that
you see under this tab as long as you're
using the service mash all of these
metrics are generated here all of the
charts are generated here every time you
end up scoping on the event timeline at
the top the time frame your charts get
updated as well so your information is
if you want to know something around
your metrics around an alert on around
something you care about you get all of
your metrics right here these are the
golden signals that Dan talked about we
have request counts error rate latency
request size all of this information
comes out of the box let's look at
Diagnostics next this is where we have
an integration with logging at the top
of the widget here you are actually
being able to see a histogram of all of
your logs and underneath we displayed a
select number of logs that have been
filtered by severity again if you're
playing and changing any of the event
timeline times at the top you're getting
an updated refreshed view
instantaneously of your logs but we know
this is not enough this is not enough
information it gives you enough
information to know if you want to
decide to look at the full logging
experience so let's say we are intrigued
and we want to look at the entire full
logging experience this has been linked
has been generated immediately for us
and we have maintained context we are
looking at the exact same service as we
were looking in the service dashboard
and we are using the exact same time
spans from over there so we can do
advanced filtering here without changing
the context at all let's say we spend
some time in logs we found something
interesting but we want to go back to
the dashboard and investigate more the
next thing we're going to look about is
the infrastructure
and this is where we have a very strong
integration of the gk team where we are
actually showing all of the information
around the requests per second and also
you have access to be able to directly
linked to the gk pods details or to the
gk cluster as well for more details so
you don't have to change we were going
to keep the context for you so as you're
doing all of your investigation you are
always constantly looking at the things
you care about
there is no filtering required and
lastly we're going to look at connected
services when we talk about root cause
analysis one of the key things that we
always ask is like is it my problem or
am i down the funnel from something
bigger that I need to pay attention to
and we are able to show you all of the
services that are inbound and the
services that out are bound to the
particular service you care about and
let's say that it's one service that you
care about so maybe the front-end
service we want to explore you can
actually go from here and start this
process all over again so now we open
the service dashboard for the front-end
service and it gives you the same
visibility and information as we had
before for the checkout service so
hopefully this is not going to be a
rabbit hole of looking at every single
service but it's really gonna help you
narrow down the things you care about so
thank you so much Patrick for giving the
demo and thank you so much for your team
that ended up building all of this
amazing work so I want to welcome next
Pat can you can you give us access to
slides so pod is an engineer service
reliability engineer working at
slamboree and we are in a privileged
position to have been working very
closely with pod for a couple of
quarters now and Pat has had early
access to our to our alpha program and
we want to talk to you a little bit we
want to do this a little bit more
informal
and we want to learn a little bit about
how slumberous architecture looks looks
like thank you rock Thunder well in
slumber chez we used to have a custom
solution that allowed us to both deploy
a monitor however this was very
difficult in the lift and shift to the
cloud we initially focused on
infrastructure monitoring with stack
driver however this proved very
difficult for our teams with both dev
and ops working together our main goal
at Schlumberger is to bring the
communities together and create an
environment were both our dev and
operations teams can collaborate and
work closely together so what's the
direction where slumber tree is heading
next we wanted a target a platform for
modern day development that was flexible
and can empower us for the hybrid cloud
environment so we turned to Google to
take advantage of the service management
capabilities built into the platform
rather than build those ourselves so I
want to understand like what was the
main reason why you decided to use a
service mash well there were three main
reasons we we wanted one was to have a
Google native manage solution
the other was telemetry and the other
was new features roll out on the
authority mat slam J we care deeply to
smartly invest our time and do effective
work for the organization as a result we
did not want to focus our efforts on
managing our own
Prometheus grow finer or sto stacks we
needed to have a managed solution
because this will empower us to focus on
what's important and is the differential
our team secondly we wanted a solution
that offered powerful telemetry we
wanted monitoring capabilities that
could help us reduce the workload for
our developers because the telemetry
from SCA go straight to stack driver
said out of the box so our developers
don't need to write that much code for
us what was really important was to have
the golden signals work just like that
without any
extra developer resources and be able to
create SLO without any homebrew
solutions it just works
without any configuration or setup we
have charts logs and s ellos all-in-one
dashboard we have a single pane of glass
that can help us monitor and diagnose
problems further thirdly it's great
where multiple teams can work on the
same platform especially when they come
from different angles
for example our architects and product
owners were looking into how to roll out
new features for a subset of customers
sto has traffic management so we can
canary new features these capabilities
were key in our decision to adopt Ezio
and gke in the end there's no perfect
solution out there however the
combination of sto and the alpha
dashboards we ended up with about 80% of
what we wanted and we thought that was
pretty great if not great and so party
mentioned that s ellos ended up becoming
kind of a key differentiator for you
making the decision to adopt the service
mesh so I wanted to know how do you
decide what what is the magic number of
SL O's how many SLO is do you build for
your organization well that's a really
hard question to answer because we do
not come up with a target in mind it's
not like we say we want 10 SL O's and
everything should fit into that number
we actually spend a lot of times across
our functional teams and try to
organically come up with a number that
can help our teams do their best work
for example we bucket services together
so we can focus on a small number of
services we do not create SL areas for
each and every micro service however we
do take a holistic approach to the
practice of SLO creation so tell us more
a little bit about that how do you
decide if a particular service is worthy
of having an SLO if I don't think it's
about a service being worthy or not
having an SLO we care about all our
services however we make
decisions based on our customers needs
we have a user journey approach to s
ellos for example one of our key actions
is for a user to log in and use our app
so the availability via our front end
service is absolutely essential here
however the front end service talks to a
number of back-end services so here we
create an SLO for the availability of
the front end and the SLO is for the
back end it depends on so we can easily
troubleshoot in case of an incident
before we used to create probes to see
if our backend service was down via
alert notifications now we can just
create s allows for those back-end
services so you just mentioned user
journeys and being able to go into your
app and see the data so how do you
decide on a relevance of a user journey
how do you prioritize which user
journeys are gonna have a salos well
traditionally we used to look at logs to
determine how the users were interacting
with our systems and any problems that
they were having however we've now
adopted a much more comprehensive effort
around user journeys and focusing on the
customer this is a team effort first of
all today we meet of our product owners
and subject matter experts and in all
these conversations we discuss what's
critical from a user's point of view the
whole process is extremely thoughtful
because this is a foundation of
everything we will build afterwards in
terms of monitoring and SLA is based on
all this information we collect from our
cross-functional teams we can prioritize
the things we should focus on for
example when should I wake up in the
middle of the night so in any service we
can degrade many things however there
are some things that cannot and should
not be degraded because these are the
entire user experience is reliant on
them so we always ask ourselves what is
fundamental part of the system what is
crucial what is absolutely necessary
so for each user journey we create
several s allies and s ellos and monitor
all those their solos together so we
conceived in
user journey in one place so you
mentioned user journey approach do you
create any other types of a salos that
are not customer facing for example yes
we have a two prong approach to s allows
first and foremost are the customer
users journey driven s ellos because we
should know when we should know before
the customer does if we have a problem
and we should fix it
secondly are the back end s ellos or the
system journey s ellos because we need
to better contracts between our teams at
slumber J we care about external
customers as much as our internal
customers so we have contracts between
the organizations and we provide the
same level of care to our internal
contracts as we do to our external users
we call this the friends and family
contract because if you break your
contract you're gonna hear about it
again again and again so if a back-end
service has a clear dependency for an
internal or external user this is
something we care deeply about it has to
be up and running our culture
Islamization to empower many of the dev
teams to be as autonomous as possible
and if a team wants autonomy in our
organization then that team needs to
maintain the contract with the rest of
the teams and keep their s ellos as part
of that deal so you mentioned the
introduction of internal contracts and
having a solo spaced on them how has
that changed the culture at lambeau J we
definitely think it has changed for the
better for example in the past we would
have how shall I describe emotional
discussions when things go wrong and
most of these conversations would happen
too late so now the main difference is
that we can talk across teams with
actual data to back those conversations
this way we are now working as a
data-driven team and things are a lot
more clear and a lot less personal
having access to good data can help us
make better decisions
communicate our intentions
needs better as well so um I wanted to
know Dan talked a lot about error
budgets and is that something that slot
machine uses yes we do they don't look
great right now in our dev environments
but we don't expect them to but what's
important is that now we have the
capabilities to see them and reason
about them before the idea of SLO or
error budgets were just theory that we
had read in many different books but we
have no way good way of showing those
now everyone can see them if an internal
or external dependency we depend on goes
down and a feature in our app starts
failing you can visually see how you're
burning through your budget with these
insights we can talk to the product
owners and agree upon a deal when
engineering should focus on reliability
tasks so I wanted to know we you've been
using a D alpha for quite a bit now and
we wanted to know what is the next
features that you would need to be
building the platform we're looking
forward to the day when there's no
manual setup in any of the SLS or error
budget I would love to see this all
automated in a way to create them we
want all this as configures code even
the configuration of the creation of
things like this so dashboards SLO setup
everything should be something we can
generate automatically and check into
code so what are the next steps for
lumbus lambo sure you've been using this
alpha you've been testing it what do you
intend to do next well I work on working
a team at slumber share where we use
transform names for our software
projects and I'm lucky enough to work on
the bumblebee project the most loved
transformer but I get the opportunity to
work on many new technologies and try to
work out how these will best benefit our
organization we call ourselves the cool
kids of slumber J due to the fact that
we get to play with the new technologies
out there but we've reached a point with
our engagement with sto where I need to
show to many other teams and evangelize
this across
a lot more broadly we need to make an
eternal culture shift in order for to us
to adopt the SLO framework
cold-heartedly and broadly at
Schlumberger a main barrier right now is
that this is alpha and we wanted adapt
this into production as soon as possible
thank you so much so dan and I have some
work to do I really appreciate your time
and I really appreciate is lambda J
committing of using this as an early
alpha tester so thank you so much for
your for your time
[Music]